what does this game look like [ __ ] in my
obs let's raise your graphics back up
after all the [ __ ] no the [ __ ]
my game crashed like six times in a row
in the tutorial oh fun
i'm here
so many issues yeah that's why i called
myself that because i had so many issues
buying a game on epic it's just a
[ __ ] nightmare every time
all right that needs to be working hello
great excellent everything's great good
good
good
i love it good great
you okay man
for you
great excellent
oh i'm happy for you
yeah i'm excited look just cause i was a
little late to the recording doesn't
mean that you guys have to have an
attitude about everything it's not from
you returning it was the gradual falling
apart during the attempts at the
tutorial that killed them
yeah we made several inside jokes as
well you'll hear them
you're not inside of them
everybody good let's replace some uh
friday the evil dead yeah what's
interesting and i did the tutorial i
still don't know exactly what we're
supposed to do all right so we load in
and in the top right corner it gives us
a clue as to where a map fragment is we
need to go to that area collect the map
fragment we do that three times
then once we have the full map it will
tell us where the book and the dagger
are we have to go get those go find the
cultist dudes hold ctrl walk in a circle
as they die and then we're done you mean
the necronomicon
yeah the west side comic book let's get
it
comic-con
is that one of those inside jokes that
was a good one shawn is suspiciously
dead silent
that's probably good
yeah well i pressed find match i'm sure
that can only end well the game has been
cancelled by a player from youtube oh
wait no
we're missing someone yeah
oh wow i'm sure he just needs a few
minutes maybe for a phone call i mean he
just made a funny intro and started
laughing and knocked a water bottle over
and just had a mark moment where he was
just like oh no
god man you're a really tiny backup
keyboard you're burning me too good man
stop burning me so hard where's my burn
song
burn song
look see and play the burn song
i'm i'm here
hey
we theorized what happened to you we
have a lot of good theories
okay hit me with him bob what was yours
uh you did what mark likes to do and and
you were so funny you made yourself
laugh you knocked a drink over on your
desk and like water damaged your
computer or your goxillar or something
no i'm not funny enough i'm not funny
enough for that our other theory was
that your shipment of graphics card came
in your your sweet 40 20 ti's and you
just started slamming them into your
computer and had to overclock them right
then and there
no they come in next week oh okay
i theorized that you fixed your game
crashing but by that you caused your
life to crash
kind of that's kind of the closest one
we have a winner
oh that's the reason i'm the smartest of
the three people
at all yeah well look internet here
[ __ ] sucks so to get fast internet
you need to get a business line
dedicated to your house which has to
have like a dish on your like chimney
that points at another building
so it's really quick there's no lag
whatever but if the weather gets bad you
lose line of sight and then everything
goes wrong and there's like a [ __ ]
weather weren't you saying earlier
there's thunder yeah there's like a
monsoon happening right now oh good i
went out and my cat's like running
everywhere because the rain is so heavy
[Laughter]
we have other internet that's like fiber
in the ground but it's not as fast but
it works for this well i'm going to
invite you and ironically your name is
so many issues and it's weird because
you've had zero during this attempt
today
for a reason don't you love how i was
like hey guys we're gonna play a game
yeah
all right let's try and play a video
game right evil dead the game versus ai
take one first attempt at this
don't patronize me guys
it's been on set for a few days he just
goes so
i have i'm a method actor take wow what
the hell does that mean it means he's an
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
do you want to be the annie nobi squad
can we do this
the annie squad
i kind of like the annie nobis
somebody's not in sync wait didn't think
oh wait a way method
out from the other annies
okay we all pick a different character
and then go back to annie okay i see
what you mean
one two three
yeah
that'll make it like believable oh it's
nice oh it's oh it's nice
like a dance troupe now it's like
synchronized swimming that's fun all
right i'm ready is this the point of
this game
yeah this is it
how do you ready wait what are you a
wizard you click on your uh your your
didn't you do the tutorial uh yeah it
didn't involve readying up yes it did
yeah i'm flattered oh
no
stop the recording
this let's play is over
who got the nobi who who ended up being
nobi i think it's bob no i got the i got
the first guy oh god
oh my god
did you guys see the same thing i saw
[Laughter]
okay how do i play this game where do i
go by the way
there's a whole mini map there's a mini
oh there's a may or may not be covered
by our faces depending on where you want
to squeeze you in uh lixie and make sure
it's as covered as possible
what is this oh i hear a demon guys i
have like an altar next to me but it's
not magic or anything it's just rocks
all right cool uh top right it shows us
where the first map pieces that we need
to collect
and if you notice the bottom middle it
shows the current level of the demons
we're facing the current level
yeah they level up so they get tougher
okay it's north of here got it
guys i'm getting when i hear one
oh my god oh you're a caller hello whoa
hey that's me
hey you weren't you're mumble mummy
i have so much fear that i'm screaming
right now my character is screaming
why why are you afraid probably because
you're crashing into everything no
the mark is behind us we lost it left it
the big circle oh sweet lord
got him
next to like a flaming barrel or
something like that here we go fire
there it is there it is get it
get out let me know
every ah steven's leveled up to two guys
just wanna let you know oh hell yeah oh
he's right here
wait
and i gotta i gotta move the car out of
the way
all right so whenever you're near a
building where the map piece is you'll
see like a red exclamation point show up
god is this slamming in the okay he got
him yeah it's fine my fear is really not
going away you good it's not you guys i
thought if you wear this red vest oh you
you back you good yeah i'm fine why are
these guys fighting oh you're oh that's
you what is the car what is happening
you're all right man
[ __ ] is teleporting everywhere what is
going on it's fine got him
it's not the same people but it made you
and me the same dude we're different
versions from different movies
i hate that it's fine i'm closer to the
original you're old and busted
i feel like a fake arm going on
i keep hearing like lots of rumbling and
[ __ ] and lots of growling
but there's a crossbow in here is one of
you guys like a crossbow dude uh no
there's a chainsaw in here maybe you can
use chainsaws chains love you ash people
maybe
what can i and can't use whoa whoa
you okay
you guys sorry there's a lot of dudes in
here
well kill them saw gun i picked up a saw
gun
i don't know what that means i don't
either well i'm about to find out that
there's a hatchet over here oh hey
looks pretty good
you want to follow me there's a chest
out here you get some pink drink to
upgrade your stuff i gotta
just run past one
[Music]
i don't know what's happening
there's so many marks what there's so
many me's
whoa
there's demons coming out of portal
holes guys i found piece of map nice
word
bob nice bob nice works the best of us
the best of us
well i am i don't know who's who
i don't either oh there's a guy one is
there's a guy next to me is
yes yeah i'm here with ash holding
pistol
oh i'm ash holding pistol that's nice
over here holding it down
oh that don't sound good oh yeah oh yeah
okay so bob is ash with actually saved
your life thank you get down ma'am
there's a lot of like gurgley horribly
ash with shotgun uh that would be me all
right enough a shotgun
whoa
whoa whoa whoa
somewhere in here they look way too like
us yeah there's two of the same guy out
here
i could mistake any one of these for you
guys i wish i could tell which ones was
you and which ones was a things i'm
supposed to kill
behind you no it was just garbage flying
in the never mind
wait okay we need to go to the gas and
go does our car still functioning oh
there's another car whoa hey bud
we should go to it
watch out
i marked our new objective
cool
watch out
you guys are doing great i'm really
proud of you
we're i'm trying to make my way
friends are we coming or no all right
right where'd that car go
oh
no this one's gonna work oh
you okay
i'm bleeding out but are you okay
i don't know if i can do anything about
the fact that you're bleeding out but
i'm coming over here i can't see
anything
demons
i'm reviving you like everyone's lagging
thank you i did i did not revive you i
did i didn't it's really i'm looking
like crazy everything's frozen
i can't revive you you're dead now you
dropped all your stuff
popped up and said you saved him rescue
their soul grab their grab his soul i
grew up just special ammo where's his
soul put his soul in the trunk i got the
car outside i i got disconnected oh my
god
all right so should we uh should we back
out yeah well you should probably back
out it was not my
day
no you had no issues
oh my god wade just bragged although
against the car
oh no marcus got out of the car and died
guys well so each character has a q
ability so like on annie it's the when
activated the skill increases range
damage from annie and any teammates who
are near her so it's important to know
what the what what what happened i
didn't press ready up so i don't i
disconnected it oh no
i want to [ __ ] die i know we disabled
cross play but i didn't think we
disabled play with your friends who live
across the
[Laughter]
thank you pond you thank you
thank you thank you
[Laughter]
funny story that was mark's actual live
reaction watching doctor strange too
you're just sitting next to me with this
mode i gave gordon
oh so funny
[Laughter]
all right we're gonna search for a match
and let me tell you there's gonna be no
issues
uh-huh
okay bobby all right
oh we're just gonna get through it
really quick
all right who will we be in all right
i'm not i forgot don't forget to mute me
oh jesus
ah christ nobsters i'm ash man look at
the dual lashes wait i had everything do
i have to mute and unmute again
yeah you gotta remute or you can go in
your settings and mute your own
microphone but that would take
selflessness
oh we're the same character right now
bob that might be the problem oh son of
a okay
i said out loud i want to be support ash
well i didn't hear that at all but here
i'll switch off no no no no no you got a
titty
yeah i'm titty ash well i'm not going to
be the other ash now i'm going to be i'm
support
oh no one gets ash
okay no i'm ash i'll be nobi
the noobster
this game is [ __ ] lit
dude so wait till you get to play
oh god
why does that happen
i'm reliving it it's showing you which
of like the three demon factions you're
up against oh i don't want
there's a lumberjack axe over here that
i apparently cannot collect whoa it's
it's a epic letter
oh wait i can collect it there's not a
lumberjack axe over here anymore never
mind you guys are close to that map or
any of you pushing into that little town
is that who what where we need to go i
marked out the minifigures
hot i need to go dude i'm just happy to
be playing the game dude i found the
altar to resurrect people when they die
i'm going i'm going towards your mark
wade
nice work good work bob good work you
find the right exclamation point in the
map again
you're our mvp
you're coming down the hill i'm going
baby support ash coming in the red is on
his way i am on the way as well
yes
are you sure yeah i made it to a barn i
see some hay or something
long gun ammo
special hurry for a long time
oh special weapon ammo lumberjack is
this bob
whoa whoa whoa wait oh oh oh
look at my hair so shiny dude you look
like my protector tell you what i did
not mean to point my shotgun at you
accident what are you trying to say
i just i'm really turned on by how safe
i feel right now
so somewhere in here
like
i'm seeing someone like predator they're
like cloaked what oh do you see this
uh
where are we looking
like right next to the lantern there's
like liquidy air
like predators oh yeah
what is that
i don't know
i
i'm in it it seems fine yeah probably
fine
who would be worried about something
like that liquid air
where are we going dude either i'm going
to red exclamation point dude there's a
shroom farm in here
oh god
that's fine is that a sword do you have
a sword i do yeah where'd you get a
sword oh there's a chainsaw oh
flavor that piece
has found the first oh
there's a crate here get your pink i'm
opening a crate right now right next to
you my bro who found the map piece
i did
well done
a blender boost you should address me as
henry
all right henry that feels weird but
don't do it
thanks nobes hidden acres is marked i
think i just healed you by attacking
that with my heavy attack guys we need
to head to hidden acres
nope it's only 200 yards away we can
make that bomb on the double i'm with
you my protector man
oh hold on give you a million dollars if
you can remember my name magic little
henry
[ __ ] henry the horn meister that's what
they call you
henry's the horn meister i've heard
rumors of henry's horn
and all night he's the mystery oh horny
he could cleave a country in two lives
it's five times the size of a normal
[ __ ] dicks no no did you do no
i saw you drop dead in front of me that
was very dramatic it was mid-bit
[Music]
oh thank you
are you guys at the i'm alone now are
you guys at the place or what we are
right there you're basically there yet
all right well
our poor friend sean seems to be of
departed
i was too good for this land
truly true
join like mid gamers
hey what's up guys hello how are you
doing i clicked invite see if that does
anything hey guys i found a piece of map
oh there you go
smash no longer exists
oh
god nice game thanks
it exists
well i guess that's all that one
whoa
what do we do now
well
die obviously
can we shoot each other apparently
hey get out of the way i'm trying to
shoot wade
ow
get him ow i've always hated you annie
i've always hated me too
ow
so slowly
oh no mark your health bar is brown is
that
bad or not
no no no that brown's the good color
i was incantacifated by dead don't worry
guys
oh dear we died in a pile you really had
so many issues today no you didn't i
wasn't there
oh god
oh i really needed the jumping animation
for that oh
i got nervous
who really wants you to see that they
say shawn 17th time's the charm i think
for sure it's this [ __ ] ain't working
for me bro
make a different game you picked this
i didn't i hate it so are we switching
to devour or something
huh what we'll do is we'll to get the
full content out of it lixian
pull up trailer footage and like test
gameplay footage and then we're all just
gonna act like we're playing it right no
one will know the difference yeah
yeah okay yeah okay all right um
go go
here i go
i'm gonna get this matte piece of acme
anchor look at what is that you
is that lightning oh
okay
[Music]
you